as the decade comes to a close we look
forward for an Eldon ring reveal is
bound to drop any money just kidding
Eldon ring doesn't exist it's a hoax
so let's look back instead and celebrate
all of the content created since the
beginning of this series I've
categorized all the content types on
screen so skip to whatever interests you
but let's start with music
if I knew where I was going on
this is we are the souls by the probe an
animation set alongside the song I
believe by Christina Perri this video
was actually taken down all the way back
in 2015 but now it's back and every line
every lyric has been expertly matched
with the visual designed to hit any
souls fan right in the fields
[Music]
[Music]
Perrault even asked me to be part of
this masterpiece with a short narration
and it's just one of the many
collaborations that I was honored to be
a part of this past decade and it all
started with Lord vessel by tanooki suit
back in 2013 who must have been among
the first to do fan songs about the
series
[Music]
[Applause]
it was the start of a sequence of soul
song edits for me and the best were
always those that were made by those who
really understood the games and were
part of the community and had led to
songs like fading light by aviators
which found outstanding success
[Music]
[Music]
and who can forget the plethora of soul
songs by miracle of sound
[Music]
[Applause]
there's also this abundance of metal
music that has been created about the
series the aesthetic of Dark Souls
matches the genre so damn well and so
far this might be my favorite
it's from the bells of awakening EP by
Visigoths
[Music]
while these artists have one or two
songs related to souls no one can match
the sheer amount of music created by
Alex ro a composer who twists existing
soundtracks into something new yet
familiar expanding upon From Software's
universe with music my personal favorite
song of his is epitaph for boletaria
inspired by Demon Souls and I've been
thinking a good role for my channel this
year I think should be as a central hub
a sort of bonfire if you will
strengthened by its connection to others
so please check out every creator that
interests you in the description wait
till the end of the video and then just
mash your middle mouse button on all of
the links that interest you when I'm
done then select all the tabs bookmark
them and wrap yourself up in a blanket
with some hot cocoa and settle down for
a long viewing because I just gave you
enough content to last you until next
month and one of the animation clips
you're gonna want to watch is this of
course I have to mention prove again in
the animation category how else would I
know what it's like to go dark souls
with your best mates
unless
[Music]
hello may I share with you the law of
this land yeah let's hear it I know it's
hard to believe but were actually
standing in a tall order
why did you do that no that was my fault
please leave a bad player of you on my
name so I may learn from my mistakes
happy souls is this incredible wholesome
animation and there are some animations
like height of despair by rice pirate
that don't need words to tell a story
and if I wasn't around to make law
videos you know at least we'd have
plague of gripes to break it down for us
with Dark Souls in summary kind of lost
the annals of history well son I'm
disappointed but I still love you
display hands your van Halen mixtape
failing that at least we'll always have
car I shall never repeat myself do you
understand what I've been explaining yes
kill more bosses damn right
Aaron's mind has a whole dark source
series featuring events that most of us
can relate to which is a segue to
Matthew says Minh who features a ton of
encounters from the game in these
immensely detailed animations that must
have taken an insane amount of effort
now you know about that right and
speaking of death his odd stava dying to
the last boss on his 41 bosses zero hits
run of Dark Souls 2
he's currently 11 hours and 53 minutes
into the run and I know it's taken him
countless hours to practice to get to
this point this might be one of the most
painful moments in Souls history but you
really have to watch the full video to
really understand the impact of this
moment it's a really well edited video
plus he just put out part 2 up on his
channel and you're just gonna have to go
over there if you want to see if he
succeeds or if he fails again
but while Oates takes the crown for what
must be the most painful moment I feel
like happy hub might take it for the
most joyous last year the day before
seculars release actually this is him in
the final moments of his souls born no
hit run
that's blood-borne Demon Souls Dark
Souls 1 2 & 3 back to back with no hits
taken
at all there are so many amazing
creators I could mention in this
category
there's lobosjr who has done almost
every challenge run Under the Sun
there's K witty who excels in sekito and
blood-borne runs and of course all the
speedrunners like distortion who create
these incredible strats for beating the
game quickly and they've proven why
these games are so damn good to speedrun
all of these creators can be primarily
found on Twitch because this is a
category that lends itself to live
streaming so go over there and you too
can be on the edge of your seat during
these moments and also shout out to
twitch chat back when twitch played Dark
Souls back in 2015 and we could all play
the game together in putting controls
and deciding what to do next
we started this video with the proved
who showed us the limits of content that
can be made with source filmmaker but
now let me show you a snippet of the
newest video by the Perry God who is
pushing the limits of what we can
achieve cinematically in game I really
love the twist at the end of this video
so for that you're just going to have to
go and check it out Perry God's work is
groundbreaking and I'm honored to have
him as a partner on my channel as he's
been responsible for most of the recent
edits bringing your cinematic experience
here to a whole other level
so please do yourself a favor and
subscribe to his channel
and while you're at it soak in the
atmosphere of this next clip and ask
yourself if it's something that you'd
want to see moral Confederate as your
stomach not turned turned at the world
of man so wondrously wretched and
brimming with unsightly vermin much like
our very own mission i feel the house
manages to represent the story of
blood-borne cinematically with nothing
more than visuals and the game's own
narrations but while Perry God is a
master of editing and field house is a
legend with barely any tools there are
no clips here that are quite like those
of sunny legend who posts on Twitter
with these unbroken cinematic clips that
are pure art the reason that creators
like us can do what we do is in no small
part thanks to the work that's done by
the modding community many of whom
create tools that make cinematic footage
like this possible these are the quiet
heroes people who identify the values in
the code that represent things like the
camera and then create tables that
anybody can use for good and evil back
in the day it was only a legendary
creator called Hellkite Drake who
publicized their findings in the games
code but leading the charge now is Lance
McDonald whose talents have created
amazing tools like being able to control
enemies in Dark Souls 3 and blood-borne
there's also tools that he's starting to
make publicly available over on his
YouTube channel and he's on earth to
countless secrets like why the flaws in
pontiff Sullivan's room are suspiciously
smooth it's because well there's a floor
sander in the Alpha files of Dark Souls
3 it's amazing what law we can uncover
with deeper access to these files truly
items texts and bosses many of these cut
as
provide context for what does remain in
the game with from software being so
secretive it's kind of the closest we
have to access to what their developers
are thinking and no one has documented
more over the years than senators Kay
and then there's illusory wall someone
who experiments a lot with what's just
accessible to the average player in 2014
for example through sheer will and
testing he started to discover many of
the fascinating secrets behind vagrants
which are those mysterious creatures
that appear in your world in Dark Souls
1 and they appear when someone in
another world loses their humanity a
great person to follow to stay abreast
of all the advances being made is zhu li
who has themselves contributed many
tools and skins and mods like the first
person mod fascicular they put me on to
stay 3d who is currently posting about
their Dark Souls 2 remake on Twitter
then moving around assets changing the
lighting and and hopefully they can
bring back some of the magic that the
game had in its pre-release demo state
and at this point there are so many
incredible high-quality PC mods for the
series some of the more famous ones that
I might show you guys soon the daughters
of Ashe remake and the scorched contract
mod and these change the game to such a
degree that it actually feels like
you're playing a director's cut of some
kind but it isn't just the hackers who
have helped us to understand these games
they're also the reviewers who break
down exactly why these games are so
special one of my favorite reviews is by
Matthew mitosis a 24 minute long video
about demon souls that forever changed
the way I view it now that we have
sequels to compare it against time and
again they threw out the rule book and
just did whatever they felt like
conventional wisdom says that struggling
players should be offered a helping hand
not pushed down a well convinced another
great video series is done by super
bunny Hawk who makes excellent points
about the evolution of Dark Souls level
design though there are exceptions the
majority of souls levels use a kind of
spiral tower layout even when they don't
look like it the player is always
turning and always moving up or down
and lastly there's h-bomb a guy who's
video on blood-borne I hope will be an
excuse for you to check out his other
content which is also really good and
there are so many more worth watching so
be sure to check them all out in the
description and it's amazing how much
content can still be made on these games
and how many of you are still into it
you'd think we'd be scraping the bottom
of the barrel with videos like how to
pacifist run dark souls 2 but anyway of
playing that forces you to resort to
this technique is surely worth watching
worth watching also are the videos by
curtain guy who speaks about some pro
level strats for adults which is
something I can finally relate to you
won't be able to damage this boss
normally they actually have a secret
weak point and that weak point is
something that we will never find
because your baby just woke up now what
you want to do is pick up your baby with
your right hand give you as you all know
from watching my videos useless facts
about Dark Souls can be fascinating and
no one presents them better than the old
man and his grandson limit the pygmies
path isn't preset you can drop him
anywhere and he will crawl to fillion or
look at him go
they'll get your wife food and how could
I not mention wild pie who all the way
back in 2014
created the first [ __ ] guide to
dark souls of all the videos on this
list a few of them were created before
2012 a year that was changed forever
with only a froze giant Dan o guess I
can't use that music it was a year that
was changed forever with the war
[Music]
so a spare a thought for all those who
not only had to deal with the an all
under watches but only afro and Inferno
plus as well honestly I feel like
there's an argument that can actually be
made for the lack of balance in these
games the fact that it's not balanced
well is actually great for the comedy
side of YouTube since there's nothing
quite like watching a team of people
getting blown the [ __ ] out by a pair of
twin dragon great swords from young
Mastro's incredible PvP montages to grim
disasters creative builds there's an
entire subsection of the community that
exists here and I can't wait for them
all to come off life support when eldon
ring is released because man seculars
single-player focused campaign really
left these people high and dry you know
it's bad when iron pineapple doesn't
even make it Shrek video on your game
that's not very nice and I'd be remiss
if I didn't mention others in the law
community whether it's by DS low-key on
Twitter who is one of the very few who
is still coming up with unique and
credible theories about the games even
up tool very recently you can also check
out ashen hollows projects Dark Souls
which covers most of the canons story
across all of the Dark Souls games or
Mitch L whose tragedy of lady Maria
video you should definitely go and check
out because then you might stop bullying
me about not doing my Maria video there
is a set of law creators who started
around the same time as I did people
like Dave control live tera mantis and
silvermont who are all worth subscribing
to as we head into Elden ring territory
and there's also a slew of sekito
content creators that have sort of gone
under the radar people like creep Ling
Bob the hollow and grim Motown has great
breakdowns of specific characters and
aegon of a stories let's talk law is
this great long format series if you
kind of need something that you just
want to put on in the background
for a few hours the bloodborne up-close
series by Richard Pilbeam gave me huge
respect for the information that is
given by textures in these games I'll
never forget that series and many of the
people I've just mentioned have
contributed to Sinclair laws podcast
where you can go to hear Richard suffer
for hours on end and of course if you
haven't already set aside a few hours to
read the pale blood hunt by DMC Redgrave
the most comprehensive work on
blood-borne story to date before the age
of dark there was the age of fire before
the age of fire was the age of ancients
and before that there was epoch
lambreaux making videos on Dark Souls
what must have been before anybody else
from him came a really popular set of
lore videos opening up a side to these
games that few had considered as deeply
at the time to all of the games he plays
ENB brings this methodical considered
approach that's honestly addictive to
watch it's so different to how I play
games and if that sounds interesting go
and check him out on Twitch for that but
back then it was really just him Quelaag
and a German spy
those three creators and then I started
doing stuff shortly after I decided to
put my own twist on these stories
because at the time I felt like they
weren't being presented in an emotional
character-driven way so that's what
prepare to cry was all about but man I
was so young back then and I don't care
who you are it's hard to look back at
yourself from seven years ago
especially when it's still all on
YouTube around that time there was also
a guy called Vegeta who did these long
format guides and commentary and one of
my favorite videos by him is his
everything possible before the gargoyles
playthrough you should check that out
although I don't think he's creating
videos anymore and a great podcast
continues to be the bonfire site chat
pod cast who have been doing this for
ages but the real content really was the
friends we made along the way right and
if you want to watch me suffer through
Dark Souls 3 with some friends then you
can always watch the Edward and the
pants series buy me crack
and bed vanilla finally we have the
artists who I hope are all busy right
now contributing to an art competition
that I'm running if you're interested in
a shot at one thousand seven hundred and
fifty US dollars and do you think that
you're good at drawing landscapes or you
know someone who is so you can
Commission them check out this video
where the goal is to depict a land from
Dark Souls that we read about in game
but one that we never really see so
drawing places like astora
or kareem or catarina things like that
you have until the end of march 2020 to
submit your entries thank you so much
for watching please take a few more
minutes to check out everyone in the
description add them to bookmarks and
I'll see you next time